knapp 30 jährige schloss gabriel alias
mit ihrem damaligen mann auszuwandern
sie hatte wirtschaft studiert konnte
jedoch von der schriftstellerei
sie wollte buchstäblich neuland betreten
wir haben entschieden nach irland sco
ohne jene lang setzten damals vor bald
30 jahre irland des gegenteils sie
schwitzend momentane kurs ihn zum ersten
mal haben wir festgestellt dass das wahr
ist dass irland ganzen an 38 vom
mentalität und vor allem für mich
wichtig ist mit landschaft
hals über kopf in die landschaft verlegt
denn im jahr ist die mischung aus
neugier und abenteuerlust sie es anderes
probieren und steht dass man sich neu
erfinden und das medium und damit alles
passt
viele können nicht verstehen weshalb man
freiwillig auf die annehmlichkeiten des
lebens in der schweiz verzichtet im
april erscheint gabriel als buch über
schweizer auswanderer geschichten aus
700 jahren zum beispiel die von heinrich
füssli der in london zum berühmten maler
der albträume wurde oder die von louis
chevrolet der in den usa als rennfahrer
triumphierte aber als autokonstrukteur
scheiterte oder das schicksal von hans
gamper der den fc barcelona aufbaute und
in der katalanischen metropole bis heute
wie ein gründervater verehrt wird
am meisten faszinieren gabriel alias die
turbulenten lebenswege die derjenige von
krok
a propos unendlich rastlos zufolge sich
stark und sehr für ihn sinn landung
nicht wichtig sein optional können
ich sehe ich als clown viele auswanderer
geschichten sind geprägt von
leidenschaft jahr von obsession und
formal ganzen eigenwilliges kämen sich
vor ihren eigenen werk das als zwölf
jahre gefühl kasimir silhouette sieht
ball treten
das ist jene hält zog in ihrem leben
blüht fälle kümmere was ist fühlt sich
ein besuchsrecht und sie hatten das
leben aber an verschiedenen orten
verbringen jetzt in den usa verbracht
mehrheitlich aber das ist mir fast
zufällig sie ursula andress das
bond-girl in terence young sdr no hatte
das land ursprünglich wegen der liebe
verlassen
die bauern im dschungel gegangen und hat
als schule michael wird sich der
schauspieler vor jetzt wo filmaufnahmen
gemacht hat in der schule wo sie gesehen
und da hätte alles mögliche versprochen
und hätten doch mal nach paris
und sie hat es an strom kommen erhält
zwischen box über die klarheit da wo
sich ihre boote hat sie ergriffen und
hedge-fonds titus gemacht und hat sehr
viel vor
letztlich zählen für gabriel al j nur
zwei arten von auswanderer geschichten
die baslerin zählt sich zu den
glücklichen die ihren ort fürs leben
gefunden haben